THE FALL:
Not too long ago,
Sam Bankman Fried, the founder of FTX, was the
richest man under age of 30. He had a net worth
as high as $27 billion, and he was even making
moves to potentially acquire Robinhood. Likely
the most impressive part about his success though
was that he was one of the few billionaires that
was able to maintain a relatively positive public
image. Popular finance YouTubers like Meet Kevin,
Andrei Jikh, Financial Education Jeremy, and
even Graham Stephan constantly pitched FTX as
the go to crypto exchange. They described Sam
as a philanthropic hippie who just wanted to
help people, and I fed into this perception
as well. While I’ve never done a sponsorship
with FTX or anyone else for that matter, I did
post a rather positive video about Sam Bankman
exactly a year ago. And let’s just say Sam was
great at playing this philanthropic monk role.
He didn’t live in some sort of California
estate with his fellow tech billionaires.
Instead, he lived in the Bahamas with 10 roommates
and drove a Toyota Corolla. But, likely the most
appealing feature of Sam for many was what he was
planning to do with all his money. From the very
beginning, Sam made it clear that his primary goal
with making money was to give it away. He lived
by this ideology of earning to give which was no
doubt extremely popular with the masses. But, at
this point, Sam doesn’t exactly have much to give
because the vast majority of his fortune literally
got Thanos snapped. In fact, Forbes estimates
that Sam is no longer even a billionaire,
and the majority of his net worth today likely
actually comes from his Robinhood stake. But,
how did things U turn so quickly? Well, let’s
just say that Sam went from promising to bailout
everyone with his philanthropy to needing an $8
billion bailout himself for FTX. Now, to be clear,
FTX says that only the international branch of FTX
is under stress and that the US branch is fine,
but take that for what you will. According to
Forbes, FTX is now worth 0, Sam’s trading firm,
Alameda research is worth 0, and FTX.US,
well at the time of making this video,
they say its valuation is unclear.
But, by the time you’re watching this,
this could very well be 0 as well. So, here’s
how Sam Bankman went from being the crypto
superstar who made $27 billion in 4 years to
losing 94% of his net worth in a single day.
NONBELIEVER:
If you’ve only been following
media headlines, FTX’s liquidity crisis likely
came as a surprise. One day, FTX was one of the
most trusted crypto exchanges in the world, and
the next day, they suddenly needed a bailout. But,
in reality, the FTX situation has been developing
for years and can be traced back to the origins of
the company. If you take a look at why Sam founded
FTX in the first place, you’ll see that it wasn’t
due to a strong belief in crypto or bitcoin. In
fact, Sam is pretty neutral on crypto as a whole.
The reason he started FTX was because he saw
opportunity. You see, before starting FTX, Sam was
a traditional wall street professional working at
a trading firm called Jane Street Capital. There,
he specialized in trading international ETFs,
but in 2017, he spotted an opportunity to trade
something much more profitable: Bitcoin. At the
time, there weren’t dozens of crypto exchanges
that were all super well funded and had millions
of users each. Most people who were into crypto
preferred to keep the majority of their holdings
in cold storage wallets and only used exchanges to
buy and sell crypto. This led to relatively
low volume across many exchanges leading to
discrepancies in price. On one exchange Bitcoin
might cost $10,000 while on another it might cost
$10,100. If you were willing to buy it on the
first exchange, transfer it over to the second,
and then sell it, you’d instantly profit $100 on
every Bitcoin you bought. And this is exactly what
Sam set out to do with his first company, Alameda
Research. After about a year of doing this,
he realized that while arbitrage trading itself
was quite profitable, the real money was made
by the exchanges who were earning $50 or a $100
per Bitcoin without taking on any of the risk
that Sam was. So, in early 2019, Sam set out to
create his own crypto exchange: FTX. But there
was just one issue: he needed money. Fortunately
for Sam, there were plenty of VC firms who were
desperate to get into the crypto space including
some heavy hitters like SoftBank, Tiger Global,
and even Blackstone. This has allowed them to
raise an impressive $1.8 billion over the past
4 years. Sam would turn around and spend this
money on developing the firm, acquiring other
crypto companies, and most important social media
marketing. They must’ve spent hundreds of millions
on marketing because they were everywhere all
the time. And when you have so much exposure,
you’re bound to get customers whether
you’re good, bad, or otherwise. Now,
I don’t think Sam was bad per se, but it does seem
apparent that Sam was in it for the opportunity
more than the crypto itself which is not exactly
what you wanna hear. We’ve seen time and time
again massive engineering companies and tech
giants whether it be Intel, Boeing, and even
Apple fall flat on their face due to leaders who
didn’t quite have the technical understanding or
belief in the product. And if that’s the case
with these juggernauts, it’s not surprising
that it’s the case with FTX. But, not believing
in crypto was just the first of FTX’s issues.
MISMANAGEMENT:
You would think that running a brokerage is
relatively straight forward if you have customers.
You charge customers a fee for connecting buyers
and sellers, and it’s as simple as that. If FTX
just stuck to this, they likely wouldn’t have
run into any issues at all. But, as you might’ve
guessed, brokerages often get greedy and look for
um creative ways for generating extra revenue.
In the case of FTX, this can be traced back to 2
risky practices, the first of which being non cash
collateral. Whenever you have cash laying around
at a bank, brokerage, or really any financial
institution for that matter, it’s rarely kept as
cash. Usually, the institution will take the cash
and invest it to generate more revenue. They
figure that only a very small portion of their
customers will actually be withdrawing money at
any given time. So, they keep some cash collateral
for this, but the rest gets invested. Usually,
most traditional institutions are forced by law
to keep this collateral in cash, but when we’re
talking about crypto brokerages, the rules aren’t
as clear. Sam decided that it was a great idea to
keep this money not in US dollars, Euros, Pounds,
or even Bitcoin. He decided to keep it in a token
that FTX themselves created called FTT. For the
longest time, this seemed like a brilliant play
given that the FTT token had rallied from just
a few dollars to $70. But, the thing to note is
that such tokens not only outperform Bitcoin to
the upside but also to the downside, and let’s
just say Bitcoin hasn’t been performing so well.
This itself likely added significant pressure
onto Sam’s companies but the real crisis didn’t
come until people starting pointing this out on
the internet. For obvious reasons, FTX customers
started to feel a bit uneasy with FTX storing so
much money in the FTT token. And the nail in the
coffin came when Binance founder, CZ, announced
that they were going to liquidate all of their FTT
within the next couple of months. This essentially
sparked a bank run FTT, causing FTT to fall back
to where it started meaning that FTX’s collateral
was now worth a lot less. Ideally, FTX should just
be able to sell their investments and make up for
any discrepancies in withdrawals but that brings
us into their second risky practice which includes
highly volatile leveraged investments. Usually,
financial institutions invest their reserves
into highly liquid safe investments like money
market funds, bonds, and mortgages. In the past,
we’ve seen that even that can lead to issues,
so it’s no wonder why using these reserves
to engage in leveraged crypto trading led to
issues. And the worst part about all of this
is that financial stress often operates in
negative feedback loops. When customers hear
that a given institution may be illiquid,
they get scared and withdraw their money. This
leads to the institution truly becoming illiquid
even if they weren’t illiquid before. And given
that most of the influencers who pitched FTX are
now telling investors to withdraw their money,
well if everything else didn’t already cause
a financial crisis at FTX, this definitely did.
And let’s just say it’s bad, it’s $8 billion bad.
BAILOUT:
If the $8 billion deficit didn't convince
you that the FTX situation was bad,
just listen to what Sam tried to do. Sam was so
desperate to get a bailout that he approached his
biggest competitor Binance and asked them to
buy FTX out. At first, Binance agreed as this
seemed like a slam dunk. Binance was already
the largest crypto brokerage by far in terms
of trading volume and acquiring FTX would
just further solidify their position. But,
it just took one look at FTX’s balance sheet
for Binance to realize that this company was
something that they’d like to stay far far away
from. Binance would make an official statement
that they would not pursue the FTX acquisition
due to mishandling of customer funds and alleged
US agency investigations. And that brings us
to where we are today with Sam scrambling to
put together $8 billion which is by no means
an easy feat even for FTX. Here’s the thing,
even at the peak, FTX was only worth $12.3
billion, so Sam is essentially asking investors
to pay 66% of their peak valuation just to bailout
the company. Who knows how much more money they’ll
need to survive this exodus of customers. From
an investor’s perspective, it makes no sense to
pay so much money and voluntarily take on such a
massive gamble. In fact, existing investors are
already doing the exact opposite by writing off
FTX as a complete loss. Sequoia, for example,
sent out a letter to their partners stating
quote “Based on our current understanding,
we are marking our investment down to $0.” And
if you can’t convince existing investors who
already have skin in the game to invest more
money and save their investment, it’s gonna be
virtually impossible to convince anyone else.
So, personally, I think that it’s just a matter
of time until FTX does officially go bankrupt if
they haven’t already by the time you’re watching
this. And even if by some miracle they survive,
you probably don’t want to be keeping your crypto
at an institution that doesn’t even believe in
crypto and now has a history of mismanagement.
SEC CRACKDOWN:
Whether FTX does end up collapsing or not, you
can bet that regulators are going to use this
situation as justification to crackdown
on the crypto industry. And honestly,
that’s probably for the best. There’s a reason the
banks and traditional brokerages are regulated so
heavily. It’s because if they aren’t, it usually
leads to end customers like you and me being hurt.
We’ve already seen two brokerages collapse this
year: Celsius and Voyager, and FTX may just be
an addition to that list. And the truth is, while
I’m sure Sam is devastated that his company is on
the brink of collapse and that his net worth has
collapsed from $27 billion to not even a billion,
it’s not like anything really changes for
him. He still has a 7.5% stake in Robinhood,
and unlike FTX, Robinhood actually has cash.
In fact, Robinhood has $10 billion in cash
and their cash reserves are literally worth more
than their market cap. So, it’s more than likely
that Robinhood will survive this recession and see
the light of day at which point Sam will not only
become a billionaire again but a multi billionaire
and even a deca billionaire. The ones that are
truly left holding the bag are FTX’s 5 million
customers, Voyager’s 3.5 million customers,
and Celsius’ nearly 2 million customers. I
mean, these three companies alone will have
affected over 10 million people and that’s just
the people affected by their direct fallout. If
we’re talking about indirect effects, it’s
likely tens of millions more. And if crypto
really is the future, it appears to me that
regulation is a must, but that’s just what I
think. Do you agree? Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you hope FTX customers
get their money back. And of course, consider
checking out our discord community to suggest
future video ideas and consider subscribing
to see more questions logically answered.